you didn't think this was the end of the
story did you
Booma you were totally right when you
said that the story wasn't over but your
revelation had a scrambling for clues
and trying to piece the puzzle together
some people thought you'd be the big bad
of descendants three but we knew that
you had a heart of gold hidden in your
treasure chest we're so happy that you
and mal were able to bury the hatchet
and become friends again but don't get
too close
or you'll make Evie jealous she's Mouse
number one gal pal after all there was
no way of knowing what would happen in
descendants three some of the film's
trailers threw us off completely so many
diehard fans came up with convincing
theories that totally checked out here
are 10 d3 fan theories that turned out
to be true we could try to be friends
put our history behind us and celebrate
our differences Audrey is the queen of
mean Audrey house hated mal ever since
she stepped foot in auradon but stealing
the future king of auradon out from
under her nose was the icing on the cake
Malon Audrey had a score to settle which
is why many fans were convinced that
Audrey would be the villain of
descendants three fans become even more
convinced when Disney descendants
released their official trailer Ben's
proposal de mal is what cemented
Audrey's evil reign Evie gets her castle
all Evie ever wanted was to marry a
prince and move into a huge castle but
she quickly found out that true love was
more important than riches and titles
luckily for Evie she has the talent it
takes to make it big in the world of
fashion so we were convinced that she
would have her first castle by the time
the descendants franchise came to an end
and as it turned out Evie bought her own
starter castle somewhere between d2 and
d3
where is Lonnie fans were completely
shocked when they realized that Lonnie
wouldn't be making an appearance in
descendants 3 but most of us only found
this out when the movie wrapped up
however some fans had already predicted
that Lonnie would be m.i.a for the
entire 3 quilled anyone who read The
Descendants books was aware that Lonnie
would be traveling with her roar team
throughout the third novel did you know
that Lonnie wasn't going to appear
three tell us in the comments Katie's
his mouse dad the entire Internet was
buzzing with theories about who Mouse
father could truly be although
Maleficent had told now that her dad was
a human it turns out that mal knew who
her dad was all along the under-the-sea
short story gave us a lot to go on but
in the end the glowing blue orb gave
Hades identity away still many of us
would never have guessed that mal knew
who her dad was and vice-versa
Hades turns out to be a good guy Hades
may have made Hercules and Megara 's
life a living hell in the past but he's
definitely one of the funniest and
sauciest male Disney villains of all
time
fans were certain that Hades would turn
out to be a good guy but their beliefs
were shaken up when they saw Hades
blasting dragon mal with his Ember we
believed that Hades would have a change
of heart by the end of the movie and
this turned out to be true we're so
happy mal in Hades get to have the
father/daughter relationship they always
wanted puma and mal team up together
melanoma becoming friends again was a
very popular theory amongst fans most
believed that Huma and mal were simply
bumping heads because they didn't know
each other well enough
Ouma might have been the threat to
Oregon in descendants - but she became
the solution to saving Oregon in d3 we
hated seeing Malin Ouma fight so we were
super happy to see this fan theory pan
out Maleficent the lizard
it's hard to believe that their
strongest Disney villain of all time is
still roaming Oregon as a lizard some of
us thought that Maleficent would return
to seek revenge on mal and her friends
in d3 and others predicted that
Maleficent would remain a puny lizard
throughout the film and while it's
unfortunate they were absolutely correct
although mal mentions that she still
loves her mom in d3
everyone seems to have forgotten about
Maleficent the lizard Queen Leah the
evil grandmother many fans were
convinced that Audrey would become a
total villain in d3 and boy were they
right but others also theorized that
Audrey's hand was being forced and they
were kind of right to
supposed to be his queen in the end
Queen Leo wasn't kind-hearted and
encouraging like the average grandmother
instead she was rude selfish and
controlling she turned Audrey into the
queen of mean and some pants are this
one coming from a mile away the barrier
comes down felon bees created a world in
which evil and good were separated by a
very fine line and lions were meant to
be crossed
till loads of fans were certain that the
barrier would come crashing down in the
third and final descendants films this
turned out to be true instead of
bringing poor new BK's to auradon every
single year auradon in the aisle put
their differences aside and became one
then proposes to mal there's nothing
more exciting than a royal wedding which
is why times of fans predicted that Ben
and mal would get hitched by the end of
d3 but surprise surprise they got
engaged at the very beginning did any of
your theories turn out to be true sound
off in the comments hit that subscribe
button and notification Bell to be the
first to watch our newest videos and be
sure to give us a big thumbs up while
you're at it thanks for watching the
things we'll see you next time
[Music]